COLT MCANLIS: Google
Cloud Next 2017
hosted more talks detailing
the future of cloud
than you can shake a stick at.
If you didn't get a chance to
catch Yufeng Guo's session,
On-Device Machine Learning,
TensorFlow on Android,
then stay tuned, because
here's the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
By combining TensorFlow with
your mobile applications,
you can create magical AI
experiences for your users
based on their custom data sets.
RETO MEIER: This is tricky,
though, since today's
mobile devices don't
have enough power
to train AI models, not to
mention that it takes terabytes
of high-quality training data to
build a new model from scratch.
COLT MCANLIS: The
solution, then,
is to split the
difference, leveraging
the power of the cloud to
drive your mobile experience.
Creating new machine learning
models is extremely resource
intensive, so the most
practical approach
is to use cloud ML to train your
TensorFlow data in the cloud,
and then deploying your trained
model on your iOS, Android,
Raspberry Pi devices.
RETO MEIER: A great
example of this
is adding customized image
recognition to your mobile app
that works in real
time and offline.
We start by gathering
the training data, which
includes the objects we
want to recognize in lots
of variations-- multiple
angles, different lighting,
different backgrounds
and orientations.
The images of each object get
stored in its own Google Cloud
Storage folder, ready for
use in training the model.
COLT MCANLIS: Training a
brand new model from scratch
is a time- and
resource-intensive process,
so we're going to cheat.
By using cloud ML, we
can leverage a technique
known as transfer
learning, which
lets us alter the final layer of
Google's massive 48-layer image
recognition model, called
Inception v3, which
handles categorization and
recognition of objects.
By leveraging the
existing model,
we can train on fewer
examples and in far less time.
RETO MEIER: Now, once your
model has been trained,
you need to optimize it before
incorporating it into your app.
A newly trained model is
typically around 80 megs,
so we want to trim that down
before putting it on a device.
To start with, we
can remove parts
of the model which are used only
for training, which can't be
used on those devices anyway.
COLT MCANLIS: We can
shrink it even more
using a technique
called quantization.
Here, we take the 32-bit
floating point values
used to represent
each pixel in an image
and reduce it to 8-bit values.
While this is lossy,
the neural network
is designed to take fuzzy
input into account when
doing identifications, so we can
lose significant image quality
without sacrificing accuracy.
Using this approach alone, we
can reduce our model by 4x,
bringing it down
to about 20 megs.
RETO MEIER: Now, when our
optimizations are complete,
we can deploy our model.
Now, keep in mind that the
model itself is still 20 megs,
so while you can package it
directly within your app,
you may want to
make it available
as a separate download.
COLT MCANLIS: Check out
the full session video
to see Yufeng demonstrate his
amazing candy sorter demo,
and learn more about
how you can use
TensorFlow and ML to create
magical experiences in mobile's
apps.
And if you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget the Next
world tour coming soon
to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]